mrs. Leakes mrs. Dean will go round in
the car this is what caring for others
looks like in Grimsby at Western primary
school where four out of ten children
are classed as disadvantaged they're
making and delivering fact lunches for
families stuck at home they're doing the
hard way really come to stay inside with
the chamber all the time not able to get
out into the paths go for a walk really
specimens lots of children there you
know anything we can do to help for
assistant head mr. Pauwels that means a
long hard walk my job we faced a lot
more than the group Zach one of the
things a bag of crisps and a walk round
they say five miles carry and just
deliver the meals and it could take and
I think what was true about how to do it
depending on how long I talk to the
parents in lockdown Britain mr. Pauwels
has the streets of Grimsby almost to
himself as he delivers lunches knocks
and retreats to the pavement he uses
some deliveries as a daily welfare visit
while for others it's an opportunity to
thank their local hero after three weeks
of delivering packed lunches mr. Pauwels
is a recognized legend but it has not
gone to his head my job is the welfare
of children educating them and in these
times I'm just doing it in a different
way you know in that way is to make sure
they're okay
at home the stay at home we have a meals
if the struggling with getting food it's
just my job really mr. Powell's sandwich
round will continue for as long as the
children needed
charitable skynews Grimsby